If you got 19 for the numerator, and 135 for the denominator, good job. Let's
see how we got that answer. When we subtract fractions, we also have to have a
common denominator. So the first thing that I need to do is find that common
denominator. When I use the factor tree method, I need a factor in common. For
45 and 27, that common factor is 9. I know that 9 times 5 is 45 and I know that
9 times 3 gives me 27. If I multiply those together 3 times 9 times 5, I get
135. The next thing I need to do is to convert my 2 fractions that I'm
subtracting into equivalent fractions with 135 as the denominator. So, I can
take 5 over 27, and I want to have 135 as the denominator. So, 27 times 5 gives
me 135 and 5 times 5 gives me 25. Now let's create an equivalent fraction for 2
over 45. Since I want 135 as the denominator. I need to mutliply 45 times 3. And
now I have 45 times 3 is 135, and 2 times 3 gives me 6. Now I can rewrite my
original subtraction problem with my equivalent fractions. So I have 25 over 135
minus 6 over 135. When I subtract fractions, I keep the denominators the same
and I subtract the numerators. 25 minus 6 gives me 19.